20 uhr willkommen zu den nachrichten
tornados in brandenburg nach hannover
was hallo leute ich wieder eure mal
wanne und herzlich willkommen aus dem
knapp weniger beton man sagen wie viele
leute das tier aus dem knast also
verbreitet den hashtag free mal wandel
der sommer ist endlich da und es ist
richtig schön warm draußen und was
braucht man wenn es warm draußen ist
genau ein kaltes erfrischungsgetränk und
deswegen heftige heute so dass oder plug
ins haus bringt in ganz verschiedenen
verrückt wird geschmacksrichtungen wie
ich noch nicht alle kennen und ihr
wahrscheinlich auch nicht sieben paare
draußen gerade beschwert haben weil ich
so viele hefte und ich denke mir ja ich
teste gerade viel weil ich bock braucht
hatte und es werden auch wieder tage
kommen an dem ich andere dinge mehr
mache als war geht es also weltjugend
und steak auf jeden fall gut für das zum
dritten mal und schon sehr gespannt und
ich hoffe ihr freut euch auch drauf und
jetzt den gamern unter euch jetzt
natürlich schon dieser kühlschrank
aufgefallen und design wird nicht nur
cool aus weil man wacht auch geräusche
also passt mal auf
und hier ist aus und unser erstes
getränk aus dem magischen kühlschrank
bubblegum sogar und da bin ich sehr
gespannt drauf holon klejbanowa alter
riet einfach wir haben natürlich wollen
wir auch schauen wie die farbe aus nicht
deswegen habe ich jetzt ntb sieht
überhaupt nicht künstlich aus oder des
vaters obmann spülmittel trinken würde
dann mal prost
ich weiß ich ganz genau was ich dazu
sagen weil also schmeckt halt nach
kaugummi aber auch irgendwie nicht so
ganz zeitig da rangegangen spülmittel
ist vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass
er kein zocker drin das ist irgendwie
komisch schmeckt aber man mitarbeiter
mit getränk nummer zwei wenn ihr diese
frucht kennt habt ihr nicht gewonnen
aber er ist auf jeden fall wieder dinge
mineralwässer natürlich ein stachel an
nun in saft stachel an ohne aber
friedlich schlechter oberflächlich
gehabt seltsam schmeckt wie melone und
auf jeden fall lag angeführt wenn ich
irgendwann allergischen schock habe ich
wenigstens kamera wasser wird sie jetzt
hinter der tür ab
red red ist eigentlich glaube ich ein
kaugummi und davon gibt es auch eine so
dann kommt bestimmt aus amerika
man könnte meinen labors oder
[Musik]
zigarettenstummel und zwar maximal aloe
vera probiert beiden polen auf jeden
fall
aloe vera saft gibt und hier glaube ich
mittlerweile auch manchmal stück de
doch diesen schwenk nicht wie mit
orangensaft mit fruchtfleisch von
mutters ab können
ich kann davon aber nicht so viel
verändert hat einen sehr an seine pläne
kaulquappen entlaste die dosen krieg auf
jeden fall entlassen weil sie so gut aus
wenn wir ungefähr in meinem alter seid
werdet ihr das nächste getränk auf jeden
fall kennen twist and drink in apfel
geschmack und das sind ja so süße
getränke in kleinen classics lassen wie
du hier oben einfach nur aufdrehen und
dann trinkt meine enkel haben mir das
ding nie gekauft ich wunder mich heute
nicht warum ich fand es als kind fand
ich super cool aber heute holen wir das
nach die kindheitsträume also auf jeden
fall sehr cool
ich fühl mich sehr cool damit auf dem
schulhof hätte ich mich noch gut gefühlt
das trinken da chris rendering schmeckt
etwas versucht apfelsaft zu sein es aber
einfach nicht hinkriege das ok als
kinder die cool gefunden und gemocht
aber jetzt erwachsener wahrscheinlich
schon richtig erfrischt aber das heißt
nicht das ende denn jetzt kommt mutter
scott spiel ohne alkohol natürlich oder
wie harry potter fans sagen hut ab ihr
habt ihr schon mal beim schmeckt's
mutter wieder selber zu machen das ist
mir nicht ganz so gut gelungen mit kenny
zusammen
ich hoffe das schmeckt jetzt besser im
kessel und zum lesen braucht es ist
richtig magisches bier schmeckt es auf
meinem karamell als ein softgetränk
gemacht hat
in harry potter fan muss natürlich mögen
eines vorweg jetzt auf jeden fall hinter
das nächste getränk durch um 10 uhr
hallo mein gott wie nie wieder was
anderes trinken schmecken erstmals
mutter vera mel und schokolade mit
getränken zwar nicht mithalten aber
genauso kämpfen oder crazy als
hauptgericht nicht gut und die müssen
was man seit 13 kann man nur aus beiden
gläsern richtig die müssen an einem
warmen tag flüssiger reis darauf hab ich
jetzt los ohne geschmack gemüsebrühe in
folge sind
mit etwas gutem unterspülen und war mit
raid also weintrauben wurde ist ja in
amerika ganz normal dass man da ganz die
mein traum sagt rink aber hier nicht so
ok die farbe violett biolek schmeckt
überhaupt nicht mein traum sagt der
finne so ein tropfen von mein traum
geschmack rein gemacht haben der rest
einfach zucker und wenn die denn mein
causa verpacken great flavours ostring
nicht zu empfehlen aber die farbe ist
voll im letzten getränk habe ich ein
bisschen an
ich habe es bestellt weil ich dachte das
nicht mutig bin bin ich auch und
deswegen zeigen euch jetzt einfach mal
[Applaus]
ihr könnt ein dieser saft wird aus der
spucke von einem vogel gemacht die leute
die dieses getränken machen sammeln die
vogel länder und kratzen die schmucke
davon ab und das kommt an der reihe und
zur feier des tages gibt natürlich ein
ganz schönes paar
vogel es gibt da sind stückchen drin ein
stückchen drin und das ist kein aloe
vera ich traue mich nicht
wien tu zwar gar nicht das beruhigt mich
schon mal andere länder andere sitten
oder wenn ihr selber ausprobieren
wollten es ich würde es nicht empfehlen
man soll auch an wenn's am schönsten ist
und diesen kulinarischen höhepunkt kann
ich auch nicht mehr übertreffen also ich
hoffe ich habe das video gefallen wenn
ja dann und ansonsten sehen wir uns bald
wieder ich hoffe ihr könnt den sommer so
genießen gerade wie ich es wird ja nicht
mehr so lange schön sein
dann kommen halt wieder die frage aber
solange die sonne draußen ist geht raus
die nicos wetter und ich werde wieder
kompletten quatsch bis dann
die kleinen vogel messer